ce dimanche 15 juillet 6000 supporters
se sont rendus au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines pour assister
à la finale de la coupe du monde france
croatie une heure avant le coup d'envoi
la fan zone affichent déjà complet ça
c'est la france et je lui ai entendu
plusieurs fois ce mot bon écoute et
voilà on est tous très heureux là
maintenant bien sûr on attend le le
résultat final
musique à fond les supporters se sont
échauffés avant le coup d'envoi avec des
chants qui laissait présager les sauver
rien à cacher
enfin retentit la marseillaise dans
l'enceinte sportive pour accompagner
l'entrée des joueurs sur le terrain
l'enthousiasmé laisse ensuite place au
stress et enfin le premier but français
arrive
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
al avantage de courte durée les croates
égalise laissant place aux doutes chez
supporteurs français puis antoine
griezmann redonne l'avantagé aux bleus
sur penalty avant la mi temps
mi temps 3 y domine mais mais voilà il
ya deux ans il ya deux ans ma gueule et
c'est pas fini c'est pas finir la voir
c'est blanc ou moins de 15 minutes après
le retour des vestiaires l'équipe de
france fait le break 3
tu viens le quatrième but de killian mba
pays
malgré la réduction du score de la
croatie la france s'impose 4 à 2 et
ajoute une deuxième étoile sur son
maillot
la fête s'est ensuite poursuivie à
l'extérieur du vélodrome nationale
rendez vous dans quatre ans pour une
nouvelle coupe du monde et pourquoi pas
une troisième étoiles brodées sur le
maillot
[Musique]